this week I'm taking you to the kitchen
because I'll be granting the layout of
recipe box up
you
[Music]
I was wondering about using material
design and fob and realized CSS I would
be quite nice for that I think that
especially if you do the project for
yourself if it's not for a client and
you can easily change some stuff if it's
better for the project if it's better
for the final user is better for the
final performance this situation is a
great example when firstly designing it
i thought i will build everything with
black spots but later when you think
okay what about fun what about this
animations is it easier is there to
build them on your own it's a child
machine right now mmm because if not and
maybe there's an easier person went to
build it of course it would be perfect
if you know everything in the beginning
back was life and the life is that
sometimes you get a new idea out of a
sudden and if it's really bad for a
project why not turn into this direction
if it was the project for a client for
sure I would have to discuss everything
with them and explain why and convince
them to this solution from use them to
choosing some you know slightly
different way communication and being on
the same page is a key
[Music]
two
[Music]
mmmm
[Music]
this is what I did this week with the
recipe box project I introduced on the
basic layout let's start with the home
page implemented it according to the
designs I prepared earlier rather you
see one folder but of course there will
be different photos each of the card is
the link there is the fab where you can
always add a new recipe this is mobile
horizontal view mobile vertical view on
smaller forms such as iphone 5 it looks
like that
ipad view and ipad horizontal view and
desktop view each of the card is a link
so wherever you click in the area of a
given recipe you will be redirected to
recipe view this is the recipe view on
desktop so that when you enter any any
recipe you can see its detail sound big
photo and you can also add it or delete
the recipe now the tax here I change it
a bit from the previous design a user
will be able to search here and also
come back to the previous page he'll
mobile it looks like that since almost
full width of the screen and mobile
horizontally and let's look at some ipod
view whenever a user clicks edit they
will go to edit view of the recipe where
we have the title to added the text to
delete or to add a new tab
there is also a place where you can edit
the ingredients and instructions
later a user will be able to say the
changed recipe or resign from the
changes by clicking council also here
there's a chance to change the photo and
the last view implemented so far as the
Creed view our user wants to introduce
completely new recipe by clicking the
fourth plus icon they will be redirected
here the form is with float label
pattern so the labels do not disappear
when you start typing but they will stay
that at the top the whole thing here is
a link so it's not important in which
point the user clicks wherever they
click in this area they will be
redirected to uploading a photo this is
the mobile view and bigger mobile view
salt tablets so I introduce the basic
layout and right now all of the views
are in separate HTML files if you wanna
have a look at the code I will put their
repository link in the video description
below when I come back to this project i
will start having react functionality i
founded the roof implementing the layout
once again because i think it's easier
for me to do firstly their basic view
and later to see how it works where i
start implementing react the separation
is pimping anything layout
and functionality in react helps me also
in deciding on the final version of the
design and on the final version of the
look of the product and that's one of
the first decisions when it comes to lay
out where really the appropriate ones
that's it for this week when it comes to
code because christmas time is coming
this week we are celebrating Christmas
time and where you are either or not I
wish you really the best time in the
year and relaxing a bit but they were
thinking also achieved it in this year
than what you want to do in the
following year thousand people couldn't
have to leave in the new year's
resolution but I'll tell you my example
how it worked last year in December I
plan few things when it comes to code
one of them was learning JavaScript the
second was writing more blog posts and
about code and the fed was learning more
about user experience and thanks it is
bloody and thanks for having some
expectations and I really developed
without the time I don't suppose I would
get the same results there are at least
three things I learned about learning to
go this year the first one is to be
careful about your choices and abundance
of things because there are many of
courses but if you don't stay focused
you can really get distracted and lance
and be nothing the second thing is to
refill your motivation everybody will
have different way of motivating
themselves but for me this love turned
out to be one of the great sources or
motivation and the first thing I
is taking small steps into the right
direction so whenever they're abused an
occasion to learn something new that's
connected with your goals that is
according to what you want to achieve
generally go for it but don't exaggerate
with their size of the project don't
exaggerate with the responsibility don't
exaggerate with that hmm with the
complexity and doing everything at once
because whenever we wanted to make
something live and implement it but we
don't divide it into small steps or
whenever we want to learn something new
but we don't do it step by step but I
wanna take the big by it can
overwhelming that's why take the small
steps hopefully the next year we will
learn together even more than this year
and you'll keep on doing keep on
developing I wish you dad and I wish you
back free coat and awesome designs
[Music]
merry christmas and a happy new year
keep on holding and see you next year
[Music]